Morgen Linus.
Morgen, Lina. Guten Morgen Tim.
Heute klatschen, hier ist sie klatschen.
Wen?
Puh, na ja, also mal schauen, ne. Aber jetzt sind wir sozusagen offiziell nicht mehr äh befreite Zone, ne.
Ja äh Apple Store macht auf in Berlin.
Ja? Ja, Zeitenwende. Und macht zu, habe ich gerade gelesen. Die Buchhandlung.
Alle, die haben doch irgendwie X.
Die Haupt äh der Hauptsitz, ich weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, was dahinter steckt. Niemals muss man dazu sagen, ist ja so eine Institution in Berlin. Also war sie zumindest.
Immer mit Büchern gehandelt.
Ja, ist auch, sagen wir mal so, die Quelle für so Tisch äh Literatur, äh jeder Form immer gewesen. Und ähm weiß noch nicht so ganz genau, was dahinter steckt. Vielleicht steckt ja Apple dahinter.
Man weiß es. Man weiß es ja nicht. Die im Laden ist ja alles zuzutrauen.
Ja. Mit ihren iPaden da.
Ja, ansonsten äh,
Seit letztes, also unsere letzte, unser letzter Schwerpunkt der letzten Sendung, wo wir Clemens zu Gast hatten, ist ja dann auch nochmal im Chaos-Radio äh aufgekocht. Ich konnte leider die Sendung nur partiell äh verfolgen.
Aber die gibt's ja zum Zeitsouveränen nachhören auch als Podcast. Ja.
Ist das so? Ich weiß von nix.
Vorbereitet.
Ja, wenn ich, ja, ich bin ja sozusagen immer der Einzige, der dann irgendwie am Schluss dann doch immer noch irgendwie die Dateien online stellt und wenn man mir sie nicht schickt.
Ich dachte, Holgi hätte dir geschickt.
Ist einfach, weißt du, dass Personal äh weißt du, wie es ist? Ja, es ist einfach äh es wird nicht besser und es ist jetzt schon schlimm. Und von daher, äh wenn man nicht alles selber macht. Aber in der Mieterebene geht immer alles online. Das kann ich dir sagen.
Äh
Ja hier kein ist ja hier kein Chaos-Club.
Ist eine eine sehr äh amüsante Sendung ähm mit äh Konstanze, Nibla und äh Linus Neumann,
als Gäste im, im Studio bei Holgi und äh zu später Stunde rief dann auch noch Clemens Schrimpe an,
äh um sich in einem Highlight der deutschen Radiogeschichte selbst Recht zu geben. Und äh,
Deshalb ist es sehr schön und leider sehr schade in der in der äh Fritz-Version des Podcasts äh kommt nicht vor wie wir mehrere Minuten lang einfach nur die Telekom-Watemelodie durchs UKW gescheucht haben. Auch das war ein wunderschöner Moment.
Wieder alles rausgeschnitten wird.
Musste wieder alles rausgeschnitten werden, weil.
Das war früher war das auch anders.
Weil sie Angst haben, dass die Telekom sie verklagt.
Arsch.
Aber es war wirklich großartig, so dieses dieses so eine Swing Mukke irgendwie so bitte warten sie.
Nee, die hatte angeschrieben, ich muss nochmal fragen, dass sie mir die mal gibt, aber das war wirklich ein ein Traum.
Okay. Okay, noch nachlegen.
Bisschen zu dem habe ich da auch erzählt, wobei dieses D-Mail-Ding, also ich ich sage da jetzt nix mehr zu. Ich habe jetzt irgendwie gestern noch einen Artikel gelesen, dass man jetzt die Ausweisfotos per D Mail zur Meldebehörde schicken soll, was,
Also,
Es war noch nie so. Ich habe mir immer überlegt, so wie wie komme ich an gefälschten Ausweis, aber weil du musst dich da ja auch immer mit diesen komischen Leuten einlassen, ne. Gut, jetzt immer noch. Du musst dich auch mit komischen Leuten einlassen, weil du so ein komisches Demailkonto irgendwie öffnen musst, ne? Aber einfach mal so,
D-Mail-Account, aber es macht auch Sinn, weil wenn du mit einer D-Mail ohnehin signierte Dokumente für denjenigen schreiben kannst, den du angegriffen hast, dann kannst du direkt einen Ausweis von dem bekommen, ne? Warum sollte offline nicht möglich sein, was online möglich ist?
Ungeahnte Möglichkeiten.
Ich sage da nichts mehr dazu.
Ja gut, sagen wir nichts dazu, äh dann können wir ja stattdessen äh über andere Dinge äh berichten, aber so richtig viel,
Ist eigentlich nicht passiert sagst du, ja?
Ja oder es ist meiner Aufmerksamkeit entgangen. Ähm was ja ganz äh was ich ganz witzig fand, ist ähm Mozila hat ähm Gamma abgemahnt,
Anscheinend, ja. Und zwar ähm.
Wegen der Verwendung von Software oder was?
Nee wegen äh der also äh weil sie offensichtlich ihren ähm,
Trojaner, äh den Finn Fischer, ähm als äh Firefox getarnt haben.
Nein. Das verletze die Markenrechte von.
Oder habe ich das jetzt falsch verstanden?
Ja, sie tarnen das als Firefox. Ja. Der Finn Fischer.
Ja, tarnt sich als Firefox. Ja. Äh betont das Firefox an sich nicht betroffen. Sage, ja ja. Also was sie, was äh gemunkelt wird, ähm,
Er hat sich Firefox unter Umständen das selber eingetreten, das Problem. Ähm das es wird
gemunkelt, dass sich die dass diese Staatstrojaner oder eine der Möglichkeiten, wie man sie, wie man diese Infektionen äh unterbreitet. Ich hatte das ja, glaube ich, auch schon mal angesprochen. Man sieht das auch in den Demo-Video bei äh Back Planet. Ist das sie,
Die Auto-Update-Funktion deines Rechners nutzen. Sei es dein dein Rechner sagt, ach guck mal hier, äh es gibt eine neue äh Version von,
von Firefox. Da gibt's ja eh jeden Tag.
Also meinst du jetzt die Auto-Update-Funktion von Mosella oder die Autoupdate-Funktion des Betriebssystems?
In dem Fall von Mozilla.
Ja, also wo Firefox selber checkt. Und jetzt erzähl mir nicht, äh das Ganze geht unsigniert äh.
Ich weiß nicht, wie's bei Firefox ist, das habe ich mir nicht genau angeschaut, aber bei vieler, bei vieler Software ist es so, dass sie natürlich erstens unsigniert kommt,
und zweitens äh auch der Kanal, auf dem sie übertragen wird, aus ökonomischen Erwägungen dann nicht äh verschlüsselt ist. Das heißt, es ist prädestiniert dazu, genau an der Stelle äh ohne
ohne besonderen Aufwand äh zu männende Mitteln und einfach was anderes unterzuschieben.
Aber unter das äh mit den aktuellen Einstellungen zumindest problematisch sein, weil da ist ja genau das, wenn's unsigniert kommt, dann.
Diese Signatursperre, ja. Ähm wie gesagt, man munkelt und ich äh kenne da jetzt nicht äh weiß nicht genau, unter welcher Betriebstrumpf.
Aber es wäre natürlich eine sehr elegante Methode, wenn man da nur in irgendeiner Form geraten kann und mal einen DNS umbiegt, äh dass man einfach.
Du musst ja nun,
also wie gesagt, sie haben ja das Produkt, haben sie ja, dass sie, also sie bewerben genau dieses Produkt eigentlich. Ähm dass sie eine eine Kiste in in den Schrank stellen beim Provider und äh die macht dann halt genau das.
Die holt sich halt den den Kontext, wer hier wer ist, weiß, wer das wer das Opfer ist und kann dann eben entweder bei dem, wenn der request kommt,
Also wenn der nächste Request kommt von einer Software, die sie haben fälschen können,
die sie als infizierte vorliefern haben, dass sie dann etwas sagen, ja genau, wunderbar, hier gibt ein schönes Update für ähm in dem Demovideo ist es sogar iTunes, aber dieses Demovideo ist auch einige Zeit alt, ähm dass sie sagen, ja klar gibt's.
Demo-Video auf Windows aber dann, ne?
Weiß ich hier nicht hundertprozentig. Also, wer es nicht kann, ich weiß, dass es bei bei vieler Software,
da kein besonders enormes äh Signatur und sonst was Checking gemacht,
bei den Downloads und dass das eine für äh sage ich mal staatliche äh Stellen sehr naheliegende ähm Maßnahme ist und wenn äh die,
Nach dann hier ähm auch zum ähm Einsatz gekommen.
Aber Mosella beklagt sich jetzt, weil das ist ja gegen ihren guten Ruf und überhaupt und wir sind ja hier eigentlich das Gegenteil von dem, was ihr macht. Ja, dann könnt ihr ja mal äh euren Softwareupdate-Mechanismus vielleicht auch mal auf,
Freiheitsstandards äh.
Also genau, hier sind drei Fälle dokumentiert, in denen sich Finn Fischer als Firefox tarnt, bei einem Angriff auf politische
in Bach rein. Im im Zusammenhang mit den anstehenden Wahlen in Malaysia, in einer und in einer Demonstration von Gamma
wo sie jeweils gesagt haben, hier, guck mal, sieht aus wie Firefox, ist aber ein Trojaner,
äh und das ist natürlich interessant, klar, wir haben das ja schon in der Folge Spike Cloud äh äh so angesprochen, Gamma ist da,
Produkt, was sie oder der Finn Fischer ist ein Produkt, was sie anbieten und da verletzen sie, denke ich schon, auch die Markenrechte von Firefox, wenn sie sagen, wir machen eine Firefox-Tour. Wir müssen auf jeden Fall jetzt mindestens ähm Gebühren für die Nutzung des Logos und des Namen,
Ja klar, also.
Na ja, klar, also wenn irgendwann mal so die Kohle von Google wegfällt, wäre das ja vielleicht eine Methode, das Projekt zu finanzieren. Aber jetzt mache ich nicht zu böse sein.
Das wären nochmal eine weitere White-Washing-Möglichkeit oder Greenwatching oder wie wir das nennen?
Ich meine das ist natürlich auf jeden Fall ist das akute Rufschädigung und das geht natürlich gar nicht, ne? Und das äh ist natürlich jetzt auch etwas, was schwer durchzusetzen ist, aber auf jeden Fall ein Punkt, ne.
Ähm ansonsten auch schon Gerüchte ist vor einiger Zeit nun ist es auch bestätigt, dass Bundeskriminalamt hat äh Finn Fischer gekauft. Also das Produkt äh Finn Fischer für,
Die Anwendung in Deutschland gekauft, interessanterweise,
ohne vorher zu klären, ob das geht. Wir hatten da ja schon äh diese äh Beschwerde vor dem Bundesrechnungshof wegen Misswirtschaft und was wir da nicht alles hatten, aber ist jetzt auf jeden Fall sowohl von Innenministerium,
als ob wir das Kriminalamt bestätigt. Nee, vom vom Bundeskriminalamt bestätigt, ja?
Doch Innenministerium im Bundeskriminalamt. Ich weiß es doch, ich bin ein bisschen müde für heute, tschuldigung. Äh Bundes,
Bundesinnenministerium und Bundeskriminalamt haben äh bestätigt, dass es jetzt diesen Kaufvertrag gibt und ähm,
Hundertsiebenundvierzigtausend Euro haben wir der Firma Ehlermann gegeben, die äh äh also Reseller ist. Es ist einfach der der andere Name damit nicht überall Gamma steht, so ungefähr in Deutschland. Ähm das ist also,
wenn du erfolgreich in Bareien und so, dann wird einen Namen machst, als Produkthersteller, dann kannst du auch oft äh die deutsche,
auf die deutsche Wirtschaftsförderung dann setzen, ne?
Ja, so setzt sich das langsam fort hier. Die Privatisierung des äh des Abhörens.
Ja, da gibt's noch einen, gibt's noch einen schönen äh Bericht, den habe ich auch nochmal verlinkt, äh wo genau das auch nochmal thematisiert wird, die Kommerzialisierung des des digitalen Spionierens, ne?
Bekomme mit einer schönen äh Grafik,
ähm wo Finn Fischer so eingesetzt wird derzeit? Zieht sich das denn überhaupt nur ausschließlich auf den Fischer? Also die Grafik auf jeden Fall.
Nicht genau, welche Grafik du jetzt gerade anschaust, aber.
In diesem Artikel äh gibt's.
Das ist ja ein längerer, der ist ja auch eine äh ein längeres PDF. Äh ja, das kann gut sein, dass ah ja, Finn Fischer ist glauberation.
Ne? Und äh,
Ja, da gibt's schon hier die etablierten Kanada, USA, Australien, Unesien, Malaysia, Vietnam, Japan, Mongole hier. Mongolei, Bangladesh, Indien, bitte?
Genau, das ist aber der Scan, wo sich Commanden-Control-Server befinden. Man könnte jetzt davon ausgehen, dass sie entweder in jedem Land, wo sie,
das betreiben auch einen stehen haben oder in Ländern wo sie versuchen es zu betreiben, weil sie haben auf jeden Fall schon mal ganz gut.
Fallstore installiert. Mhm.
Wenn also die, wo die Dinger dann sich hinmelden, aber ja, da haben sie schon mal ganz gut was was aufgebaut.
Ähm ansonsten noch einen Hintergrundartikel äh empfohlen von Matthias Monreui,
ähm bei bei Netzpolitik org, der mit dem Titel Bundeskriminalamt schulte Tunesien und Ägypten kurz vor dem arabischen Frühling in Techniken zur Internetüberwachung. Klar, wir haben ja auch Ahnung davon und wir wollen da ja auch den Leuten,
Das heißt also, da schließt sich dann auch der Kreis.
Wissen wir jetzt auch, warum die Revolution geklappt haben dann.
So sieht's aus.
Sie mal jemand gefragt, der davon Ahnung hat. Das ist aber Hardcore finde ich.
Das amtingelte in regelrechten Tupperpartys durch Europa, Nordamerika und Israel und erklärte die Anwendung deutscher Trojaner. Später durfte sich auch der britische Trojanerhersteller Gamma
präsentieren. Es ist gut möglich, dass das BKA im Rahmen seiner Lehrgänge
zur Internetkriminalität und so weiter. Die Behörden in Nordafrika ebenfalls in der Nutzung digitaler Spionagewerkzeuge unterrichtete.
Es ist gut möglich, ja. Na ja, also das auch noch mal Matthias äh recherchiert ja immer sehr äh tief,
ähm kann man auch nochmal lesen. Es ist also alles noch sehr viel schlimmer, als wir denken.
Mhm. Längere Artikel auf Netzpolitik Punkt ORG.
Gut.
Ich dachte dieses, ich hatte gehofft, dass dieses ist es alles noch viel schlimmer als wir denken, dass das so dein Einsatz ist für eine eine Überleitung.
Ich war gerade daran nachzudenken, was diese Überleitung sein könnte. Ja.
Viel schlimmer als wir denken. Ja, ja.
Das leidige Telekom äh Thema ist verlässt uns nicht und die Telekom,
macht irgendwie auch keinen Hehl daraus, dass ihr eigentlich jetzt versuchen, maximal so zu den ins böse Lager äh zu wechseln,
getrieben von, ja, maximalen Gewinninteresse, was im Übrigen auch natürlich bedeutet, dass davon die Bundesrepublik Deutschland finanziell profitiert, ja,
Falls sich irgendjemand wundert, warum die Politik nicht wirklich was dagegen tun wird, äh ja, umso mehr die Telekom verdient, umso mehr verdient dann auch der Staat mit,
Aber davon abgesehen äh nachdem wir uns jetzt lange über diese äh Drosseln ähm.
Über diese Drosseln unter äh unterhalten haben, die ja einerseits neu angekündigt sind, andererseits aber auch in dem Sinne gar nicht neu sind. Ich habe mir das jetzt auch nochmal genau angeschaut und festgestellt, also,
Es gibt bisher keine Drossel in den Verträgen, außer in meinem,
Also außer in dem Produkt äh VDSL25, VDSL fünfzig, den sogenannten Call und Surf Climbin,
und da stehen halt schon exakt die selben Drosselwerte drin, die sich jetzt auch für künftige VDSL-Verträge
ausgegeben haben, sprich die zweihundert ähm einhundert und zweihundert Gigabyte im Monat,
Allerdings mit anderen Drosselungen. Die Drosselung, die in meinem Vertrag drinsteht, ist äh sechs Megabit down und ab habe ich jetzt grade vergessen, aber auf jeden Fall alles und indiskutablen Bereich.
Für für sie äh indiskutabel, weil sechs Mbit dich ja nicht anreizen nachzubuchen. Damit kannst du ja noch halbwegs arbeiten. Ja, dich schon.
Upload ist im Arsch. Also ich meine, ich habe vor DSL nicht wegen des Downstreams, sondern wegen des Upstreams,
Also das ist einfach ich toleriere das auch nicht. Ich hätte mir das auch nicht geholt, wenn ich gewusst hätte, dass sie diese Drosseln entforschen. Ich wusste ja, dass es die gibt,
Aber äh ich wusste auch, dass sie nicht in Forst werden. Und habe sie sozusagen nur so als Papierdetail zur Kenntnis genommen, aber ich hatte halt von anderen,
Nutzern dieses Vertrages, das gehört. Was mich nicht ganz klar war, ist, dass die Entertain-Variante, also da, wo man dann quasi noch dieses Fernseh,
Gedöns dazu bekommt, dass die eben drosselfrei ist oder beziehungsweise war jetzt bis April.
Aha, aha.
Das heißt, in den Entertain-Verträgen ist keine Drossel drin. Was natürlich auch sehr interessant ist, weil,
angeblich, wie sie ja sagen, dieser ganze Entertain-Kram da gar nicht mit reinspielt. Ja, wenn das keinen Unterschied macht.
Dann in dem Vertrag keine Drossel drin gewesen und,
In dem normalen VDSL schon, ja? Äh also das gibt einfach so viele Stellen, wo man ihn irgendwie äh da mal einen Finger in die Nase stecken kann,
Jetzt ist es natürlich so, alle sind gleich, ja?
Ähm worüber wenig berichtet wurde, was ich jetzt auch nur als äh zitierte Aussage eines Telekomvertreters mitbekommen habe, ohne da einen Beleg für zu haben,
oder einen weiteren Beleg für zu haben, ist die Tatsache oder beziehungsweise diese Behauptung,
sie meinen, dass dieser Video on demanddienst, den sie über Entertain auch noch haben. Also es ist ja so, Entertain ist ja einerseits Fernsehen,
Ja, du kannst darüber Fernsehen gucken, so wie man das eben auch sonst tut. Außerdem gibt es aber auch noch Videoverleih. Und die Aussage war,
Telekom-Vertreters, dass dieser Videoverleih sehr wohl äh die Drossel aktiviert, also dass dieser Traffic mitzählt.
Das muss man dann mal sehen, ja? Ob das äh wirklich so ist. Ähm da haben sie sich ganz elegant erstmal aus der Schusslinie gebracht, weil wäre äh weil der Dienst ist ja nun wirklich definitiv nicht,
den normalen Fernsehangebot eines Kabel äh Netzbetreibers zum Beispiel zu vergleichen,
Auch wenn ich das ehrlich gesagt auch anders sehe als Clemens. Also ich finde auch die Tatsache, dass dieser ganze Fernsehkram da mit rüber geliefert wird, weil das bringt ihn auf jeden Fall einen einen Vorteil auf den Markt und es ist,
so, dadurch, dass sie das äh unbegrenzt anbieten können, äh nehmen sie das Interesse an anderen Providern auch schon mal also an anderen Videos, Stream, Anbietern raus.
Es ist genau dieser Punkt, also technisch gesehen mag es, keine äh keine Netzneutralitätsverletzung sein, weil es kein Internet ist. Markt
mäßig gesehen, ist aber da der Zugang mit dem Inhalt verknüpft und äh da wird eine eine Stellung ausgenutzt, ja.
Und deswegen ist das äh verabscheuenswürdig. Die manchmal bin ich überrascht von mir selber, was ich so im Halbschlaf alles rede. Ähm,
was ich aber noch ganz spannend finde, es gibt denn dieses diese schöne äh Interview in dem dann der Herr Nick Jan van Damm,
sagt ja ach wir sind offen für Gespräche mit Anbietern um ihre Angebote in zu integrieren oder neue Kooperationsmodelle zu finden,
Ein Teil der Erlöse würden wir dann in den Netzausbau investieren können.
Dann ist es auch denkbar, dass die Sendung nicht das Datenvolumen der Nutzerverbrauchern im Mobilfunk machen wir das bereits mit dem Musikstreaming-Dienst Spotify. So wird etwas wäre sowohl mit Marktgrößen wie YouTube, als auch mit New Kammern möglich.
Also ganz, also jetzt wirklich, jetzt, jetzt legt er halt.
Runter.
Runter und sagt ähm und das ist dann, das ist dann wirklich, also das ist da wirklich richtig perfide. Ähm da sieht man diesen diese unterschiedlichen Begriffe der Diskriminierung,
Nick Jan van Damm sagt, wir wollen diese Möglichkeiten diskriminierungsfrei anbieten. Das heißt, wir reden mit jedem über diese Modelle,
der sich bei uns anbietet. Also ist absolut diskriminierungsfrei. Der redet mit dir.
Muss es nur Geld.
Nur bezahlen, kein Problem.
Ja. Wir diskriminieren niemand, der uns bezahlt.
Wie ist dieses schöne Zitat bei Full Metal Jacket? I don't look down und Niggers, Greezers.
Ja, diskriminierungsfrei. Der Typ ist absolut diskriminierungsfrei.
Oh Mann. Ja.
Ja. Also ähm Diskriminierungsfrei heißt natürlich genau, dass sich dass sich die Diskriminierung nicht
bezieht auf die einen die Zahlen und die, die nicht zahlen, dass man, aber das ist ja die, seit Jahren diese Argumentation der Telekom, die sagen also, wir wollen Dienste, Klassen und innerhalb der Diensteklassen diskriminieren wir überhaupt nicht,
Ja, aber sie wollen ja dann unterschiedlich, ja, das sind ja unterschiedliche, das sind ja ganz unterschiedliche Klassen.
Ja, es gibt.
Ja, also so wie, wir wollen eine erste und eine zweite Klasse, aber innerhalb der ersten Klasse sind alle gleich.
Ja und was wollt ihr eigentlich?
Genau. Ist doch völlig also die einen sind halt gleicher als die anderen, aber ja äh komm.
Tja, ist wie im Flugzeug, auf First Class, geht's auch allen gleich gut.
Genau, da wird keiner diskriminiert in der ersten Klasse. Die sitzen alle gleich, wir haben genau gleich breite Sessel.
Warum sollte es irgendwie da anders laufen als mit den Steuerklassen, ne.
Also wunderbar, es ist äh aber ich bin inzwischen auch ähm hänge ich dieser dieser Theorie an,
Äh oder oder finde ich die äh die Interpretation sehr naheliegend, dass die Titel kommen jetzt einfach mal sagt, ja komm,
Jetzt wissen wir ja, was uns entgegenschlägt. Jetzt machen wir einfach mal komplett Nägel mit Köpfen und dann passiert einfach erstmal drei Jahre überhaupt nichts. Und dann können sich die ganzen Internetfuzis da irgendwie äh zu Ende schreien. Und wenn wir dann wirklich
zweitausendsechzehn anfangen den Haaren abzudrehen, dann steht da eh keiner mehr auf, weil das Thema drei Jahre alt ist. Und,
Ich habe jetzt echt äh,
Ähm große Sorge, dass das halt klappt. Am Rande sei dann noch angemerkt, dass sie irgendwie ankündigen, ja diese Kappung soll dann soll dann doch für alle äh Kunden
stattfinden und weiß der Geier, wie sie das wieder hinkriegen wollen
und dann hat sich die Bundesnetzagentur jetzt auch irgendwie eingeschaltet als Randmeldung. Äh ich weiß nicht, Bundesnetzagentur, also komm, äh also was von denen zu halten ist, weiß ich auch nicht. Ja, in welcher Form haben sie sich,
Ich habe das noch nicht mal gelesen. Bundesnetzagentur.
Ja, also nochmal zu dem neuen Sprich, der hier äh stattfindet, ja, ist ja auch sehr interessant, wie sie irgendwie äh davon reden. Er ist so den die normalen Leute hätten ja nur Internet und der
das, wovon jetzt alle reden würden, das wäre ja Managed Services, so nach dem Motto, wir garantieren euch hier äh bestimmte Qualitäten und so, ja. Ist mir auch neu,
Ähm also sie sie lassen wirklich auch nichts unversucht und äh letztlich ist ja die Ankündigung, dass die,
ganzen Drosseln zwanzig sechzehn gelten sollen, spätestens zwanzig achtzehn dann für alle, ja? Ähm,
Das heißt auch für die bisherigen Verträge oder was, ja?
Ja ja also fehlt noch mir fällt noch ein, was ganz spannend ist, äh wenn man sich mal den das das Gesamtdatenvolumen überhaupt anschaut, das entwickelt sich ja äh in der Tat exponentiell,
oder oder auf jeden Fall mehr als linear, äh steigt das Gesamtdatenvolumen nach um. Das heißt, es ist echt mal eine spannende Frage. Wie weit kommst du überhaupt zweitausendsechzehn noch mit so einem mit deinen fünfundsiebzig Gig?
Ja, kommste, also dass wir sie sich nochmal verschärfen im im Vergleich zu heute. Ach so und ich habe jetzt hier gerade, ich erinnere mich wieder, wie wie mit welchem, also mit welcher Keule,
Man möchte staunen, was die, was die Bundesnetzagentur jetzt rausgeholt hat für eine Keule in diesem Streit mit der Telekom, ja? Sie haben einen Fragenkatalog dorthin gesendet.
Oh Gott.
Und Inhalt des Fragekatalogs ist andere, unter anderem, wie transparent und Netzneutralität geregelt werden. So sieht's nämlich aus. Und jetzt kann die Telekom, jetzt kommt die Telekom.
Zittern sie.
Ja, jetzt zittern sie. Jetzt müssen sie überall drunter schreiben, äh wir bieten unser Angebot diskriminierungsfrei an. Und dann sagt die äh Bundesnetzagentur, ach so, ja, sorry, ähm,
dann ähm.
Ach komm, also so einen Fragenkatalog. Ich meine, da zittern wir doch alle davor. Auf dem einen vor der Tür steht und sagt, hier, Fragenkatalog.
Jetzt aber hier mal äh.
Ja. Das ist ja reinstes T-Baging ist das ja.
Ich habe ihn hier in Fragekatalog. So und jetzt äh wollen wir mal sehen, was sie alles wissen.
Eine totale. Ich bin gerade nicht so gut zu sprechen auf die Bundesnetzagentur.
Ja, kann ich gut vorstellen, ich bin auch nicht so gut zu sprechen, auf die Telekom, ich meine, was ich auch absurd finde, ist, sie klagen über die unglaubliche Belastung ihres Netzes. Ja, das ist ja sozusagen so, man, man sieht so richtig so mit Schmerz verzerrten Gesicht, so, oh Gott.
Wir sind gerade noch soeben in der Lage, unsere Dienste aufrecht zu erhalten, weil alle, weil so viele böse Sauger das Internet kaputt machen
Und dann fragt man sie, was ist denn überhaupt so? Äh jetzt müssten ja alle Angst haben. Nein, es müssten nicht alle Angst haben, weil der Durchschnitt liegt ja nur bei fünfzehn bis zwanzig Gigabyte,
Da frage ich mich natürlich, wenn der Durchschnitt fünfzehn bis zwanzig Gigabyte ist,
Was ist eigentlich das Problem? Ja, also äh geht's noch? Das ist ja nun kein, ich meine, was ich gehe, aber ich habe nichts, ja? Nichts ist das.
Gibt's dann auch jetzt grade, da tut sich der äh ein von diesem Routerhersteller
Den kenne ich eigentlich gar nicht, wie prinet oder so heißen Nil. Äh der Typ der kommt ja jetzt immer häufiger nach vorne und sagt dann einfach mal und das finde ich auch mal ganz wichtig. Ähm,
der sagt, ja, also so eine Gigabyte, das müsste die Telekom,
unter einen Cent kosten, weil uns kostet das ja nur null Komma null zwei vier Cent und wir sind noch nicht mal die Telekom. Ja, also der äh der einfach mal als äh größerer äh ich ich suche mal diesen Artikel kurz.
Man kann davon ausgehen, dass der Traffic, der durchschnittliche Traffic eines DSL-Kunden in Deutschland die Telekom krasse dreißig Cent kostet,
Und wenn man sozusagen so viel Daten verbraucht, dass es vielleicht, dass diese Summe irgendwie über zwei Euro steigt, dann bricht das Businessmodell der Telekom auseinander.
Im Moment, achte mal, also er sagt, wir selber zahlen als Kleinverbraucher,
Simon Kissel heißt der gute Mann. Als Kleinverbraucher in einem Backbound-Netz sechs Euro pro garantiertem MBIT
garantierte Brandbreite kannst du umrechnen, garantiertes Mbit sind im Moment zweihundertdreiundfünfzig Gigabyte im Monat,
Das heißt, für ein Gigabyte bei allen Mbit zahlen sie null Komma null zwei vier Euro. Also,
Äh ja zwei.
Komma vier Cent.
Ja
So. Und er sagt, die Telekom betreibt aber ihr eigenes Netz. Das heißt, die haben nicht irgendwie nochmal, wir sind Reseller eines Backbons an einen Provider und machen irgendwie Marge, das heißt, die Telekom,
muss deutlich unter einen Cent pro Gigabyte legen.
Ja, Times hat das ja auch schon erläutert. Man muss ja so mal klar machen. Alle anderen Provider sind halt im Wesentlichen so Dezix, das heißt, die vernetzen sich untereinander, um so äh ihren Traffic auch frei untereinander auszutauschen.
Die Telekom ist sozusagen daneben nochmal mit ihrem eigenen Netz und lässt da auch nicht jeden,
ohne weiteres ran, ja? Weil wir sind ja hier die dicksten und so weiter und man kann auch davon ausgehen, dass sogar ein Teil, das schließt natürlich jetzt nicht so Sachen wie äh YouTube, äh Facebook et cetera ein, wo es jetzt definitiv zu fremden Ländern geht, aber
nicht wenige Dienste liegen ja unter Umständen auch innerhalb der Telekom Infrastruktur, das heißt so der Traffic zum Beispiel äh zwischen,
Das Böse bittet, was hier sozusagen äh äh aktiv ist, ja, spielt sich wahrscheinlich auch weitgehend oder was heißt weitgehend, also zumindest zu einem,
Nennenswerten Teil auch innerhalb dieses Netzes ab, in dem überhaupt keinerlei Interconnectgebührenanfällen. Also diese ganze Rechnung, man kann's jetzt mit tausend Beispielen äh weiterzerren und dehnen,
Es gibt keine wirkliche Begründung dafür, sondern die einzige Begründung für diese Maßnahme ist, wir haben uns jetzt hier mal äh das Ding mit der Drossel ausgedacht, weil das ist ja schön, um hier äh so ein bisschen ähm.
Kohle zu machen, beziehungsweise generell den Wert des Anschlusses zu senken, um dann eben den Preis zu erhöhen. Was ich sehr interessant finde, ist, dass sie ja überhaupt keinerlei Aussagen darüber treffen,
Was denn das Angebot ist für Leute, die mehr brauchen. Ja, also auf welcher Basis heißt es, dass man fünf Euro mehr zahlt und dann hat man,
hat man die Flatrate wieder oder ist es wie ein Mobilfunk, dass man dann für jedes jedes Bit darüber hinaus vergolden muss.
Das sind im Moment jetzt erstmal scheißegal. Das Entscheidende ist ja, dass sie dir dass sie mehr Geld mehr Geld abnehmen können. Und da werden sie, ich vermute,
Also ich ich weiß ja aus aus leidlicher Erfahrung wie solche Menschen denken. Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass sie das genauso machen werden,
Das ist für dich möglich ist, aber etwa etwas umständlich und ein bisschen zu teuer,
Volumen nachzukaufen, sodass du eigentlich,
Bis in den höheren Tarif zu gehen. Genauso ist es ja auch bei den äh sagen wir mal diesen äh äh Telefontarifen jetzt einfach nur so einen iPhone-Tarif. Die haben's ja irgendwie ML XL oder was, ne?
So und jetzt wenn du oder S und jetzt bist du in diesem S-Tarif,
von mir aus äh Minutenkontingent X. Da drüber kostet dann die Minute dreißig Cent,
Das heißt, sagen wir, wenn die eine Grenze bei fünfzig ist, bist du mit sechzig,
dann schon nah an dem Preis für das nächste Paket, wo du aber dann halt nicht fünfzig hast, sondern hundert, ja? Das heißt, sie, sie wollen dir den Anreiz schaffen, in das größere Paket zu gehen.
Ja, ich meine, der Anreiz, ich gehe sowieso gerne in das größte Paket, ja, ich meine, sie sollen bloß einfach mal sagen, was jetzt Pause ist. Weil, was ich auf gar keinen Fall will, ist, ist ein eine Leitung, die sich irgendwie anders verhält.
Ja und wenn sie beschließen, ihre Preise steigen, okay, dann steigen ihre Preise. Das ist das eine, ja. Nur, dass es halt irgendwie,
total sinnlos ist, wo wir in Deutschland sowieso schon bandbreitenmäßig total hinterherhinken mit dem Rest äh oder zumindest mit,
Wichtigen Teilen der Welt oder zumindest manchen Teilen der Welt, die einfach mal zeigen, wie es hier eigentlich in Deutschland dem Land der Infrastruktur äh äh zu laufen,
habe, ja, dass dass wir da immer noch so hinterher,
hinken. Ich will einfach schnelles Netz, ich habe jetzt nochmal geguckt irgendwie, letzter Monat, jetzt der April sind hier in der Metaebene nur in meinem Studio,
Ist ja noch nicht mal so, dass ich hier irgendwie die ganze Zeit Filme runterlade oder so ein Scheiß, ne? Ich mache hier einfach mein Ding, ich mache hier Backups, ich mache Dropbox und so weiter,
Hier gehen fünfhundert Gigabyte über die Leitung.
Hätte ich auch gedacht. Ja und ist auch in Ordnung so.
Ja, das juckt die die Telekom auch kaum, ja? Weder wirft das nennenswerte Kosten auf, noch noch belastet, dass ihr Netz äh über, geschweige denn den Anschluss hier sollen sich einfach mal.
Also das das haben wir ja auch glaube ich ausreichend behandelt. Es geht denen ausschließlich darum, hier den die den Leuten die Luft abzuschnüren, um sie um sie zu merken und das ist auch der Grund, warum man.
Und ähm eben die den Anbietern sozusagen von Diensten jetzt äh die auch noch zur Kasse zu bieten. Also eigentlich würde ich fast sogar sagen, es geht primär da drum, jetzt bei YouTube äh Hand aufs Mal. Und ich frage mich halt jetzt ehrlich gesagt, wie wird Google reagieren?
Schön wär's, wenn sie.
Fiber to the Home.
Ja, das wäre natürlich äh eine schöne Antwort. So.
Google sagt heute, ihr holt die Sparten, wir legen Glas. Wir graben jetzt mal Berlin um. Ja.
Genau, wir wir graben jetzt mal Berlin um. So, weil mit der Telekom klappt das ja nicht.
Ich würde, ich hätte an Google Stelle schon längst hier Rosinenbomber mit IP-Paketen über die Stadt fliegen lassen.
So weit wird's noch kommen, ja. Ja, wenn die IP-Pakete wirklich so in so kleinen Fallschirmchen irgendwie abgesetzt,
Ciao. Was haben wir noch?
Die Bundeszentrale für gesundheitliche Aufklärung,
Ja, die Bundeszentrale für ähm gesundheitliche Aufklärung,
hat ein äh Onlineprogramm gebaut für uns und für die Jugendlichen insbesondere mit dem sie die offline bringen wollen,
eine ähm das hilft.
Eine Online-Webseite zum offline gehen,
In Zusammenarbeit mit der Telekom oder was?
Es ist sehr geil. Äh sie haben äh ins Minus Netz minus gehen Punkt DE. Das andere Leben heißt die äh Kampagne, ja,
Und was du dort machen kannst, dort erfährst du dann Aufklärung als Jugendlicher, ja, wenn du zu viel im Internet bist.
Und ähm ich habe mir die Seite da mal so ein bisschen angeschaut, dann haben sie so ähm so Suchttests,
Ja, also es gibt, gibt so klassische Tests, wo man dann sagt, so ja, äh also sie sind für Alkoholiker äh genauso wie für drogenabhängige und jetzt offensichtlich dann auch ähm weil man
dem Testentwickler gesagt hat, jetzt heute ist Internet für Internetsucht, wo dann irgendwie so ähm,
da sind dann so diese klassischen Suchtfragen, haben sie ähm wie oft wie oft bist du online, ja? Und die Maximalkategorie ist täglich,
Das andere ist dann irgendwie so alle drei Tage oder so, ne, also.
Täglich ist schon das Maxim.
Na, ist ja das Maxim.
Oh Gott, ich bin am Anschlag.
Man nennt das äh Deckeneffekt, was sie dann da demnächst in ihrer Statistik sehen werden, aber das äh ich will jetzt nicht schon wieder anfangen zu nörden, ja, aber,
sich da eine, sie haben sich da eine Frage gebaut, die nicht trendscharf ist. Na ja, auf jeden Fall ähm kannst du dann so zum Selbsttest hier. Dann fragen Sie also, wie oft bist du online?
Haben dir deine Freunde schon mal gesagt, du sollst weniger offline sein? Hast du schon mal mit deiner hast du schon mal mit deiner Mutter gestritten deshalb oder so, ne? Äh wirst du nervös, wenn du nicht online bist, äh freust du dich manchmal schon darauf, das nächste Mal wieder online zu sein?
Also solche, diese das sind ist wirklich äh eins zu eins. Hier genau,
Wie häufig spielst du Computerspiele? War das dann? Ja, okay, aber online haben sie das gleiche, ja. Äh welche Spiele spielst du und so einen ähm,
Genau, dann muss man hier, ähm, Kästchen kann man dann markieren, wann man am meisten online ist und so,
ja? Und solche, solche, solche Sachen. Genau, wie häufig nutzt du das Internet in deiner Freizeit?
Nie einmal im Monat einmal pro Woche mehrmals pro Woche täglich sind die fünf Antwortkategorien. Okay, lassen wir, lassen wir das. Also haben so einen klassischen Suchttest, ähm kenne ich aus in dieser Form noch so ausm Studium. Ähm.
Und dann äh sagen sie dir am Ende, wenn du dich denn da durchgeklickt hast, äh sagen sie dann
in der Gefahr bist ne, deine sozialen Kontakte zu verlieren und dein Leben zu ruinieren, weil du zu viel im Internet rumhängst. Und dann haben sie also einen Online,
ein Online Angebot wo dir dann geholfen werden kann bis zu dass sie dir irgendwie Therapeuten oder ein Coach.
Also ich will das nicht. Ich will das jetzt nicht generell verlachen und sagen,
Es gibt niemand, der damit ein Problem hat und äh das ist jetzt völlig äh neben der Spur. Es ist vollkommen klar, dass es Leute gibt und auch Jugendliche gibt, die definitiv ähm,
soll ich sagen, den Halt in sonstigen Strukturen äh die sie bräuchten, nicht haben, um irgendwie mit so einer Netzaffinität dann auch wirklich in allen Situationen immer klar zu kommen,
Das ist nicht anders als mit anderen,
Aktivitäten und Isolierungsmaßnahmen, den Jugendliche generell immer ausgesetzt sind und nicht nur Jugendliche. Von daher,
halte ich es auch für keinen Fehler, dass sich Gruppen und am Ende auch das Bundesgesundheits,
damit auseinandersetzt. Was ich allerdings hier so als Meme wiederfinde,
Und ich glaube, das ist auch so der Grund, warum wir da so ein bisschen äh kopfschüttelnd äh einsteigen, immer in so eine Thematik. Das ist so dieses generelle,
Die reale Welt und die virtuelle Welt und irgendwie dieses äh ja diese generelle Hervorhebung des
des nicht digitalen als das wahre, reine, gute, ursprüngliche und damit dann auch bessere, gesündere, rettender und was nicht alles, ne? Und ich glaube, das ist genau.
Punkt, wo wir so als digitale Eingeborene äh einfach eine andere Erfahrung gemacht haben
In dem Zusammenhang, wo du das nämlich jetzt hier gerade so auf den Tisch legst, äh sollten wir noch mal verlinken, einen schönen Artikel, den ich gerade vor ein paar Tagen
entdeckt habe auf eine sehr schöne Side, wo der Bericht zu finden ist von einem
Autor, der also auch so in den Tischbereich online äh schon seit Jahren schreibt, der seit ewigen Netzbewohner ist und der dann so ein bisschen Burnout mäßig,
beschlossen hat und dann auch von seinem Arbeitgeber dazu geraten wurde doch mal komplett auszusteigen für ein Jahr lang kein Internet.
Um beschreibt zu seiner Erfahrung, wie denn das gewesen ist. Und am Anfang war das auch ganz großartig und äh ja und endlich mal, weißt du, dieses klassische Buch lesen und den Leuten reden und überhaupt und ja, also er hatte noch ein Telefon, es ist jetzt nicht so, dass er komplett undigital ist. Es ging halt konkret nur um
Internet. Also die klassischen Dienste, E-Mail et cetera. Das war alles irgendwie no. Ja,
Aber dann so nach einem halben Jahr schwenkte das dann doch sehr um. Und er merkte, dass,
ja dann nach dieser anfänglichen Begeisterung des anderen, das ist ja auch mal so so ein Wechsel, ne, ist ja dann auch mal hach, jetzt ist alles anders und toll, also so ein Wechsel kann auch an sich schon mal ganz gut sein, aber ein Jahr ist schon wirklich eine Menge Holz und er ist dann eben schnell.
Auch vereinsamt, weißt du? Und äh,
fand sich dann doch äh äh nicht wieder, wie er irgendwie nochmal den nächsten Trail äh aufgesucht hat und äh äh das eine, ein Abenteuer an das andere äh mündet,
sondern im Prinzip dann äh vom Fernseher auf äh auf der Couch sitzt und und das wissen, das ist der interessante Punkt,
Einfach in zunehmendem Maße keine Möglichkeiten mehr gefunden hat, mit den Leuten, die ihm nahe stehen, zu kommunizieren. Wo er vorher sein Freund, der gerade
wie man ein Jahr nach China gegangen ist oder so. Äh problemlos über Facebook hat äh Kontakt halten können und auch ansonsten über äh Timeline soziale Netzwerke und E-Mail und andere Wege äh eben in Kontakt geblieben ist. Fiel das jetzt irgendwie komplett weg
Und am Ende ähm ja, am Ende zieht er dann wirklich ein krasses äh Fazit. Das ist ja auch gleich der erste Satz des Artikels.
Sehr interessant zu lesen, vielleicht in diesem ganzen Zusammenhang nochmal einen Debattenbeitrag.
Ja
Ich bin, also ich ich weiß halt, also ich meine, ich was mir ich kann ja noch mal sagen, was mich jetzt an dieser, an dieser Seite stört, ja, also an dieser ähm.
Eine Aussage vielleicht noch die, die in diesem Artikel noch drin war, da kam ich nämlich jetzt auch grade drauf. Er meinte so,
Dass das richtige Leben irgendwie sehr viel mehr virtuelle Elemente enthält, als irgendwie dieses digitale äh Leben, ja, also dass gerade so dieses real virtuelle Ding äh,
Teilweise würde ich genau andersrum ist. So, aber was stört dich jetzt nochmal an der.
Mich stört daran, dass das einfach so schlecht ist. Weißt du.
Umsetzung meinst du.
Ja, also wirklich.
Unser Programm, hier ist unsere Webseite, jetzt haben wir's getan.
Jetzt haben wir eine Webseite gemacht, die hat ein Schweinegeld wahrscheinlich gekostet, dann machen sie, dann verlosen sie da irgendwie T-Shirts. Ich meine,
wenn ich mich durch dieses blöde Rätsel klicken könnte, wenn da nicht irgendwie die ganze Zeit irgendwelche blöden Flash-Fedias kämen, dann könnte ich jetzt ein T-Shirt haben, wo draufsteht, macht den PC aus, sonst lösche ich das Internet.
Das können die ernsthaft aufm T-Shirt drucken. Da ist es.
Martin, PC aus,
lösche ich das Internet.
Totaler Scheiß. Also und dann wieso ins Netz gehen DE, ja und überhaupt, also du hast noch nicht mal also du musst doch mal so ein bisschen evidenzbasiert an so einer Sache drangehen.
Sie wollen das Internet löschen.
Ja, wer hat denn vor allem, wie kommen die überhaupt auf die Idee, dass es Leute mit äh.
Nicht sonst.
Doch das sonst ist da ganz klein, ist auch ein typographischer, also ist alles ein großer Albtraum.
Ja, das stimmt.
Da musst du dich bewerben. Ähm siehst du das ein kleines sonst?
Ach ja, da steht's. Mach den PC aus, sonst lösche ich das Internet.
So, aber so kannst du doch nicht ernsthaft an die Sache rangehen.
Nee, vor allem, wir hätten schon noch einen PC.
Vor allem nicht mit dem Onlineprogramm. Also wir machen eine Webseite, wo du die aus dem Internet rausgehen kannst.
Dass das schwarze Loch.
Das ist der Ausgang.
Der Ausgang Exit.
Hier lang zu oder was? Da ist ja keine.
Notausgang DE, ja da hätte man dann sozusagen, ja, wie bei Träumen, also Strahlenmäßig von so einem Rasterstrahl äh kleingepixelt aus dem Netz rausgezogen.
Also ähm,
Das ist einfach so äh ich meine, was sollen sie auch sonst machen? So, sie können natürlich irgendwie nicht an so eine Chance Kampagne äh an den Erfolg jetzt andocken mit mit Internet so, ne? Aber äh so ein bisschen mehr.
Platz.
Ja? Und dann halt dieser dieser wirklich diese diese äh Suchtscreenings, ne, die nämlich auch ähm also wo sie sagen,
Also sie haben quasi den Selbsttest Internetsucht, ne. Und wenn du jetzt dann sagst, okay, wie gesagt, sie haben sowieso schon mal,
ganz offensichtlich keine Vorerhebung gemacht, weil das das erste, was ihnen aufgefallen wäre, wäre, das tägliche Internetnutzung heutzutage einfach
normal ist. Sie werden da keine Variationen mehr drin haben. Außerhalb bei ganz jungen Kindern, die keinen eigenen Rechner haben, ne. Das heißt, sie haben offensichtlich kein bisschen,
sich darüber Gedanken gemacht, wie man sowas mal ordentlich entwickelt überhaupt, so ein Erfassungsprogramm,
und letztendlich ist das also das Niveau eines Bravo-Tests,
wurde mich immer am Ende dann stehen muss, selbst wenn ich da jetzt ankreuze, ich bin einmal im Monat im Internet, dann wird da am Ende stehen, ja,
Bisher ist dein Internetverhalten nicht kritisch,
Pass aber bitte auf, dass du nicht süchtig wirst.
Ja
Und das ist das also,
genauso wie diese äh ein. Wenn du wenn du dich auf eine eine Sucht oder ein ein ein Fehlverhalten testen, prüfen möchtest, dann kann dir der Test ja niemals sagen, ey alles in Ordnung. Trink ruhig mehr,
ja? Kannst ruhig noch ein bisschen äh hier Internet gucken, mach mal, ist ja auch äh zur kulturellen Teilhabe mal ganz gut. Das macht der natürlich nicht und das ist halt deswegen ist es per se von vorneherein ähm,
undifferenziert und ist einfach eine eine Schande für äh ja und das ist nichts anderes als eine als eine psychologische Beratung und Datenhebe. Und da muss ich als Psychologe sagen, das ist eine Schande für die Zukunft.
Ja und überhaupt? Man geht nicht mehr online. Man ist online.
Richtig. Und also es es ist wirklich so was von anachronistisch ja äh,
Ich ich frage mich, was die man sieht ja, dass da offensichtlich doch äh Webdesigner dran gearbeitet haben, die zumindest technisch ungefähr Sachen umsetzen können. Ja, das heißt, die haben
haben Ahnung. Man sieht der Webdesigner, der die Seite gemacht hat. Der war jetzt nicht die Erste, die er gemacht hat. Was hat der sich gedacht?
Hat sich gedacht, hier irgendwie was ist das denn? Auf dieser Webseite.
Sound. Vermutlich oder hast du gerade einen Keks gegessen.
Gesunden Bananenchips sind aber lecker.
Da kannst du wahrscheinlich hinklicken und.
Hofert man so rüber.
Einfach versteckte Buchstaben.
Mein Gott.
Versende an deine Freunde eine animierte IK zum Thema.
Ja, das ist überhaupt das.
Hier die übrigens äh online sein mit Maß und Spaß. Also komm.
Geil. Ja, kannst du jetzt hier schön da.
Ja aber weißt du, genau das machen doch Kinder, die ach so und dann kriegst du direkt erstmal eine,
Kriegst du erstmal direkt eine Warnung weg, weil die Flash Plugin auf einmal mit dot com arbeitet.
Ja, okay, also müssen wir jetzt nicht länger äh äh kann man sich mal anschauen, aber es ist wirklich, es ist es ist eine Schande für die Zunft und es ist eine es ist traurig für die ähm,
Es es zeigt einfach.
Ist ein Beleg, dass irgendwie.
Genau, es zeigt die Hilflosigkeit und also du es ist einfach traurig, ja.
Traurig, ja. Gibt noch viel zu tun. Ja, letzter Punkt.
Ja, die äh ein Thema, was wir immer wieder am Rande äh berührt haben. Wir hatten ja auch schon äh die Kirsten Fiedler in der Sendung äh zu Gast, die sich in Brüssel mit der Datenschutzreform,
auseinandersetzt. Da ist jetzt eine große äh gemeinsame äh Aktion ähm gestartet worden von ähm,
die im Moment jetzt,
also,
Privacy International, Access International European DJ und auch dem Verein digitale Gesellschaft. Ähm wo es also eine eine Postkartenaktion jetzt gibt. Da kann man also eine,
ähm,
Irgendwie eine Postkarte äh designen mit so Netzmotiven irgendwie mit und Troll Face äh so äh Postkarten mit nackten,
äh
machen. Und da kann man dann einen äh Slogan draufhauen, nämlich entweder Downlead Cooperation strip me of my ride to privacy oder insgesamt Protect my privacy. Und diese Postkarten, die werden dann tatsächlich gedruckt.
Und da kann man sich dann den äh,
So den den Member of the European Parlament aussuchen, an denen die dann gesendet werden soll. Das heißt, äh um jetzt nochmal den Vergleich hier zu den E-Cards bei äh ähm,
äh ins Netz gehende Gehen Punkt DE. Äh hier kommen also tatsächlich richtige Postkarten, die im aus dem Internet rausfallen,
Und im richtigen Leben ankommen als Postsendung.
Bei dem Teilwohl, vor der Nutzung des Netzes.
Muss man online sein.
Muss. Mit Flash.
Mit Flash-Flash, ja. Ich glaube, Leute, die Flasche haben wir See verloren.
Läuft.
Mit anderen Worten hier diese Datenschutzreform ist nach wie vor umstritten und es wird hier kräftig äh gefightet. Was ist jetzt ähm nochmal, also ich habe das Neues ganz verstanden, was die eigentliche äh Initiative ist, die jetzt hier
Also geht's jetzt primär um diese Karten oder ist es jetzt nur eine Begleitmaßnahme des.
Eine eine Begleitmaßnahme, es gibt ja dann auch noch äh Berichte über dieses Thema äh und es geht also hauptsächlich darum, dass wir so diesen,
Lobbyansturm auf das europäische Parlament haben dem jetzt entgegengesetzt werden soll, dass es da eben auch die Interessen der Zivilgesellschaft gibt, die natürlich wie so häufig äh unters Rad,
zu drohen, äh zu kommen, zu geraten drohen, ja.
Ja, das äh bringt uns dann zu der Frage, ob für den in der nächsten Woche überhaupt produzieren werden.
Republika und äh äh wer das noch nicht mitbekommen hat, Republika ist äh einer von zwei äh Ausnahmezuständen in der Digital äh Kultur im Jahr. Der eine findet halt immer so um Weihnachten herum statt, die andere eben im Mai,
und äh so ziemlich unser vollständiges Umfeld dürfte dort äh aktiv sein auf die eine oder andere Art und Weise,
Vortrag zuhören oder sonstwie teilnehmt und ja, für mich ist es jetzt sogar eine super busy Week.
Super busy week,
Super.
Ja, hier im äh Namen der der der Pottliebe äh startet ja jetzt schon am Wochenende vorher irgendwie der Workshop und danach geht's dann mehr oder weniger direkt in die Aktivität auf der Republika über,
und ja, ich bin gespannt. Wir haben da ein eigenes Studio vor Ort, das Sendezentrum.
Gibt's da einen Link zu? Wo denn?
Äh ja. Äh du kannst mal auf Sondersendung. Äh die Strich Sondersendung Punkt DE äh marschieren. Nochmal drauf äh verlinken dann auch hier. Und ähm.
Oh, ein neues Produkt der Metaebene grinst uns an.
Ja, quasi, also das ist jetzt auch äh vor allem ein Kooperationsprojekt mit den Geaks hier, mit den WikiGeks, mit Ralf Claudia und auch noch vielen anderen Podcastern, die sich da,
äh dazu Gesellen werden, ist also eine sehr äh dynamische Geschichte. Wir wollen da möglichst viele Podcaster,
und wer sonst noch bereit ist, mitzuhelfen, vor Ort einbinden, um dann irgendwie unsere Livesendung dort äh einmal am Tag hinzubekommen, die immer von siebzehn bis neunzehn Uhr sein wird,
halt live hier im Sendegebiet.
Und ja, vor allem sind wir auch vor Ort, wir sind da präsent im eigenen Raum, wir wollen dort auch äh,
gefunden und angesprochen werden. Wir sind selber sehr gespannt, wie sich da die Dynamik äh so entwickelt, aber ich hieß es einfach für notwendig und das ist etwas, was ich seit der ersten Republika im Prinzip gefordert habe, dass es mal einen Ort gibt, wo die,
publizierenden, ja?
Auch da sind, also ich fand das immer so etwas absurd, dass man die ganze Zeit dadrüber redet äh im Internet zu publizieren, aber sich das im Wesentlichen immer aus,
aufs Twittern, aus den Gängen und Vorträgen äh reduzierte. Ja, natürlich, es wurde zwischendurch auch nochmal so ein bisschen geblockt. Schreiben kann man ja überall, aber eben die Leute, die im äh Audioaufnahmen, die hatten in dem Sinne keinen Ort
und ja, wir sind ja grundsätzlich auch, sagen wir mal, im Video-Podcasting nicht abgeneigt, nur machen halt die meisten Leute einfach Audio,
Aus gutem Grund und von daher bieten wir dort auch die Möglichkeit für Podcaster dort,
also wenn jetzt sozusagen jemand vor Ort ist und für sein Programm seine eigene Sondersendung auch machen möchte, dann,
wäre das sozusagen der Ort. Das Sendezentrum auf der Republika.
Oder einen Vortrag hast du auch mit dem Radio Universal. Genau. Und ich hab einen mit dem Erkenntnis der empirischen Träuforschung für die ich gestern bis fünf Uhr morgens versucht hab irgendwas vorzubereiten.
Ja, die Situation, in der wir uns jetzt alle befinden, als äh klassische äh wird das natürlich alles immer bis zur letzten Minute gesammelt im Kopf, bis dann irgendwann dieser dieser Explosionsmoment kommt. Du kennst dieses Gefühl? Nee?
Nee. Ich kenne andere Gefühle.
Andere, ah, na ja, bei mir ist das auf jeden Fall so und ich kenne Menge Leute, denen geht's ähnlich. Aber das wird schon alles irgendwie.
Das kriegen wir schon alles hin. Nächste Woche werden wir also dann sehen, ob äh sich netzpolitisch genug tut. Es gab auch auf Netzpolitik org dann nochmal einen Hinweis zu den netzpolitischen Vorträgen auf der Republika. Den verlinke ich jetzt auch nochmal. Ähm.
Die gibt's da auch.
Es gibt äh selbstverständlich äh immer bei der Republika dann äh Moment, ich gucke mal.
Republika. Es gibt natürlich auf der Republika dann immer auch sehr viel zu der ähm,
wie schreiben sie es denn, dass sie auch.
Publica, jetzt politische Vorträge auf der Republika
Was ist denn hier? Die Maschinen lesbare Regierung elf Uhr am ersten Tag, damit geht's äh los hier. Lorenz äh Maz hat von Open Data äh City und der sich ja extrem im Open Government, Open Data Bereich einsetzt.
Dann zwölf Uhr fuffzehn Political Advox Internet, Benz Scott äh sagt dir das was.
Wenn's Gott
äh ähm hat sich früher in den USA sehr stark äh für die Netzzentralitätskampagne eingesetzt und war dann eine Zeit lang ähm Berater von Hillary Clinton,
eben auch für digitale Gender. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was sein Jobteil war. Ähm,
Äh irgendwie so also so so ja Berater der der US-Regierung für für irgendwie äh Fortschritt und und Netzfreiheit oder so.
Und wohnt jetzt seit einiger Zeit in Berlin.
Mhm. Dann kommt äh Birgit äh vielen bekannt als Mitglied des isländischen Parlaments und auch äh für Sprecherin für Wiki Leaks und
und äh andere Maßnahmen und auch eine der treibenden Kräfte in dem Versuch, den er jetzt leider gescheitert ist, äh Island eine neue Verfassung zu überhelfen, die ja in so einem basisdemokratischen Weg gefunden wurde, aber dann letztlich dann doch von der
politischen äh äh rechtslastigen Kaste oder sagen wir mal generell den politischen,
von dem politischen System Islands abgewählt wurde oder nicht gewählt wurde. Darüber wird dann berichtet sicherlich sehr interessant, ob das jetzt auch schon,
Das letzte Wort war keine Ahnung. Äh ja, ich weiß nicht, lohnt sich das jetzt hier äh die ganze Liste durchzu.
Ja, jetzt haben wir angefangen, jetzt haben wir angefangen. Also dann.
Länger als ich dachte.
Joe Joe McNamy von European Digital Rights über die Privatisierung der Rechtsdurchsetzung. Ähm insbesondere im Copyright Bereich. Dann und Stefan Pann Heusen,
ähm,
Über politische Mähmesse York, früher bei Global Voices, jetzt bei der IFF. Äh Jeremy Zimmermann und Katar Zina,
den Nachnamen kann ich immer nicht aussprechen. Die setzen sich äh natürlich auch mit ähm,
mit Datenschutz auseinander, äh also Harmlosigkeit von Daten, wie.
Heißt der Vortrag, genau, fünfzehn Uhr fünfzehn, dann sechzehn Uhr von.
Ah, von ja okay, dann setzt er sich wahrscheinlich ja, die sind natürlich als Browserhersteller an einem schönen, offenen Web, wo alle schön HTML ist äh interessiert. Ähm,
Michael Umland und Sonja Schönemann,
checken mit dem ZDF irgendwas, ein cross-mediales Projekt des ZDF. Äh okay, scroll mal runter, wie viele kommen denn da jetzt noch?
Klang jetzt nicht so äh ja wie ich schon sagte und das ist nur der erste Tag. Also.
Oje. Oh, das war nur der erste Tag. Scheiß.
Ja, ja, ja, das können wir jetzt, glaube ich, äh, wirklich, äh, vergessen, aber, äh, wir verlinken einfach mal auf diesen Artikel
es ist einiges zu holen. Auch ansonsten ist, glaube ich, so einiges äh zu holen. Ist auch der eine oder andere äh Lokbuch Netzpolitikgast hier äh am Start hier. Hier.
Und Rene weiter.
Genau, also ja und wenn ihr auf der Republika seid und wenn ihr uns über den Weg läuft hier dem dem dem Linus könnt ihr dann wieder mal ein Bier kaufen.
Oder eine Marke.
Oder eine Mate, je nachdem wie gebrochen er bereits aussieht.
Ja
Und generell, weil ich immer wieder weiß, dass der ein oder andere da zögert, spricht uns an. Sagt hallo, irgendwas, äh wir warten nicht viel, aber wir finden das immer super mit ähm,
und Hörerinnen in Kontakt zu kommen und ihr müsst jetzt keine Riesengeschichte und kein Scoop unterm Arm haben.
Reicht, wenn ihr einfach kurz sagt so, geiler Podcast. Kann ich ein Autogramm haben?
Das Beste überhaupt.
Nee, aber nee, das ist wirklich geil, das ist äh das ist das Entscheidende der Republika und äh genau, ich kenne immer noch die Wenigsten äh der Hörer. Wir sehen ja in den Downloads, dass es auf jeden Fall mehr sind als wir kennen.
Bisher kennengelernt hast, ja.
Also da gibt's noch ein paar, die sich mir noch nicht vorgestellt haben.
Genau, also nehmt euch ein Herz, sagt einfach hallo und äh alles ist gut. So, das äh ist für uns einfach auch wichtig, mal zu merken, dass das äh wertgeschätzt wird, wenn es den wertgeschätzt wird. Und.
Wobei, wobei ich.
Motivation.
Ich verlange, von äh Logbuch Netzwerk Hörern, dass sie nicht sagen hallo, sondern ist ganz klar, was sie sagen.
Guten Morgen, Linas. Egal, wie spät es ist. Das bringt uns zum Ende der Sendung.
Ja
Beginnen mal äh wir gehen dann mal klatschen, ne?
Ja, wir gehen jetzt klatschen beim Apple Store.
Alles klar, bis bald.